authenticity in tunisia with the country
going to the polls for a controversial
constitutional referendum thousands of
police national guards and
counter-terrorism units standing by
many in tunisia hoping that monday's
referendum will help improve the country
we expect the referendum to lead to a
better life for our children's children
to have a better life for us it's over
why are we living under pressure schools
are a disaster the situation is
catastrophic everything's a disaster
but not all are expecting this what will
bring change
i'm not going to vote because we've
voted a lot of times without the results
we were expecting it's the results which
forced us to not vote and not give any
importance to it because the reality
will remain unchanged and i do not
imagine there will be a change in the
future
tunisia was hit hard by covet 19
pandemic that triggered nationwide
protest in july last year paving way for
president kaisaid greater hold on power
he suspended the democratically elected
parliament then in march he dissolved it
completely
this referendum is also being seen as a
world of confidence forsyth
while the opposition urged people to
boycott it side pushed for them to take
part
that is despite electoral standards
requiring him to remain neutral
we will build together with our arms
ideas and determination we will build
god willing a new republic we will build
a new republic based on real freedom and
real justice and national dignity
because there is no dignity for nations
except with the dignity of its citizens
with a fifth of the workforce unemployed
and poverty levels soaring to new highs
tunisia the country that sparked the
arab spring uprisings across the region
is once again at the crossroad in 2019
during the presidential election the
turnout was over 56 percent and now
despite only around 28 percent of waters
going to the ballot box it will still be
enough to ensure kaisei's plan to
consolidate his power over parliament
the government and judiciary and the
fear here now is that this may pave the
way back to authoritarianism
al jazeera tunes